ja herzlich willkommen heute für einmal
als frankfurt am main hier lehrte einer
der bedeutendsten philosophen unserer
zeit jürgen habermas diese woche feierte
er seinen neunzigsten geburtstag ein
denker der sich immer wieder in
öffentliche debatten eingemischt hat
seine auftritte sind rar geworden
doch seine stimme ist nicht wegzudenken
aus der öffentlichen arena
der 90 jährige greift immer dann zur
feder wenn sein moralischer kompass
alarm schlägt
theorie und praxis das vereint habermas
wie kaum ein anderer
mehr als 50 bücher übersetzt in 40
sprachen
sein werk umkreist die frage wie eine an
verständigung orientierte öffentliche
debatte den demokratischen rechtsstaat
erst ermöglicht jürgen habermas fordert
eine ethik die sich aus dem diskurs
ergibt normen können dabei erst
entstehen wenn wir den anderen als
person einbeziehen und daraus
solidarische verantwortung unter
individuen ableiten den anderen
einbeziehen in den streit um das bessere
argument nur so kann gemeinschaft
entsteht
jürgen habermas der große philosoph
zeigt uns unermüdlich worauf es in
diesen aufgewühlten zeiten im
wesentlichen an kommt ja im folgenden
wollen wir die philosophischen ideen und
die politischen forderungen von habermas
etwas genauer unter die lupe nehmen die
schlechte nachricht ist aber mal selbst
sitzt nicht hier
dafür aber zwei seiner bedeutendsten
schüler sailer benhabib ist professorin
an der yale universität
usa professorin für philosophie und für
politikwissenschaften und rainer forst
ist professor für philosophie und
politische theorie hier in frankfurt am
main herzlich willkommen ja irgendwas
hat ein sehr umfangreiches werk
geschaffen
viel zu lesen was ist denn aus ihrer
sicht seien seine wichtigste idee sein
wichtigster gedanke ich würde sagen dass
es der begriff von kommunikativen
vernunft in seine frühe arbeiten hatte
das manchmal interaktion genannt
manchmal hat das an verständigung
orientiertes handeln genannt aber
vielleicht am einfachsten müsste man
kommunikative vernunft als die
vernünftige auseinandersetzung der
menschen miteinander verstehen dann
dieses modell von auseinandersetzung so
einfach wie das klingt hat implikationen
für ethik hat implikationen für
öffentlichkeits theorie hat
implikationen für demokratietheorie und
auch natürlich kann man das auch von
sich
wissenschaftstheorie und
sprachphilosophie noch tiefer erklären
und interpretieren arbeit glaube das war
sein grundgedanke immer seit der
früheren aufsetzen
ende der sechziger jahre überarbeit und
interaktion es ist dieser begriff die
immer noch die kommunikative finance
genau was das ist wollen wir dann im
verlauf der sendung auch ein bisschen
genauer hören was hätten sie geantwortet
er war ich hätte auch so geantwortet und
vielleicht mit bezug auf das frühe buch
die habilitationsschrift von 1962
tschuldigung den strukturwandel der
öffentlichkeit den bezug zu kant
hergestellt weil wir schon vielleicht
habermas als von der größe der
philosophie mit kant vergleichen können
aber eben auch mit den inhalten von
kants philosophie verkannt war die
öffentliche gebrauch der vernunft die
eigentliche kritische instanz
die vernunft kann nur öffentlich indem
sie ihre erkenntnisse offen liegt dem
diskurs aussetzt erkenntnisgewinne
sowohl auf theoretischen wie praktischen
gebiet machen und diese öffentlichkeit
des diskurses spielt eine große rolle
deshalb ist wie viele zu recht gesagt
hat die kommunikative vernunft nicht nur
einen von und die ich verwende sondern
die wir gemeinsam verwenden so jetzt
kommt also das heißt mit anderen in
austausch treten argumente austauschen
und begründen ein vernünftiges gespräch
suchen und die führen und das ist ja
auch sozusagen der kerngedanke in seiner
diskurs ethik wenn ich das richtig
verstehe ich fand es faszinierend in der
vorbereitung und das noch mal zu sehen
also wenn ich das richtig verstehe
fordert da wirklich so etwas wie ein er
sagt dem herrschaftsfreien diskurs einen
vernünftigen diskurs und was moralische
richtig ist was gerecht ist das kann nur
im gespräch zum vorschein kommen
eigentlich kommt aus so darf erfahren
dass ethik uns nicht so sehr sagt wie
wir handeln sollen sondern wie wir
miteinander reden sollen
habe ich das richtig verstanden das
haben sie richtig verstanden wieder ein
kantiger gedanke der kategorische
imperativ bekannt sagt ja dass ich meine
subjektive handlungsmaxime prüfen soll
ob sie ein allgemeines gesetz werden
könnte und habermas übersetzt diesen
gedanken diskursiv das seil das an einem
beispiel verdeutlichen
also wenn ich in einer handlung
situation bin und mich frage wie soll
ich handeln ja dann ist das moralische
handeln eines das ich so prüfen muss als
ob das was ich jetzt tue nicht jedermann
und jederfrau gegenüber mit guten
gründen rechtfertigen könnte ja das
heißt ich baue mir nicht irgendeine
moralische normen sondern nicht
antizipiere mögliche gegen einwände
nicht nur der direkt betroffenen person
sondern aller die sagen könnten wie
kamst du auf die idee so zu handeln
und deshalb ist das moralische denken
von vornherein einen diskursiven denken
und hamas hat dies in der kantischen
tradition eben ausgearbeitet und daraus
eine diskurs ethik übrigens im dialog
mit seinem guten freund
und kollegen karl otto apel
ausgearbeitet und das ist innerhalb der
gegenwärtigen ethik diskussion ein
wichtiger ansatz und wenn man sich
abarbeiten kann aber jetzt kann man
sagen das ist eine schöne idee dieser
herrschaftsfreien diskurs wohl nur die
argumente eine rolle spielen
gibt es denn das überhaupt in der
realität also habermas spricht glaube
ich vom zwanglosen zwang des besseren
arguments und nur das soll nicht
überzeugen nicht irgendwelche rhetorik
oder macht oder sowas
aber die realität sieht ja schon ein
bisschen anders aus also vielleicht kann
man auch die sekunde hinter der
diskothek auch eine idee also ein
gedankenexperiment fassen also
sicherlich gibt es in der gesellschaft
sogar in der familie in inter-
persönlichen beziehungen gern keine
herrschaft beziehungen die ist ein
bisschen man muss das nicht dann also
eine schlechte kopie aber wenn das
ethische werden dass kehrten der
keltischen gedanke hier vorkommen sollte
dann heißt das wir müssen mit einander
als gleiche umgehen das heißt dass ich
nicht darauf zwingen kann ein
handlungsmaximen akzeptieren
woran du überhaupt die ich nicht also
ein beteiligt fast an also die
rechtfertigung kommt von draußen raus du
hast kein schlechter erkennen also diese
idee von einer gleich beteiligung gleich
beteiligung und also einander als
gleiche spalt partner anzuerkennen und
das hat wahnsinnige implikation also das
muss als kritisch jeder verstanden
die forderung ist jede und jeder soll
gleichberechtigt mitdiskutieren können
und das sagen sie haben ja gut das hat
enorme folgen wenn man das ja praxis
übersetzt zb zum beispiel also ist die
idee der demokratie ohne so ein gedanke
möglich also dass wurde immer
im grunde detail überarbeitet demokratie
sagen seit dem 17ten jahrhundert also
lockt cantu so war immer also mit dieser
konstanz begriff verbunden
das war so ein gedankenexperiment dass
der politische ordnung ist legitim wenn
ich als freiwillige und gleiche dafür
zustimmen würde und meine zustimmung
geben würde also das ist auch eine kante
aber es ist auch eine idee was könnte
auch sehr von russo gelernt hat na also
der grinten grundidee hinter der
diskothek ist dass auch unsere
vorstellungen von gerechtigkeit und
fairness
mit dieser form gleichberechtigung
verbunden sind was kommt denn bei
habermas dazu jetzt nachkommt und
rousseau wir müssen wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen moralischen
normen die in einem strikt
universalisierung sinne rechtfertigbar
sein müssen da spielen
staatsbürgerschaften usw keine rolle
wenn ich irgendjemanden gegner der in
not ist oder demgegenüber ich ein
bestimmtes maß an respekt aufbringen
muss dann ist die frage ob wir den
gemeinsam im gemeinsamen pass haben oder
so völlig irrelevant
auf der ebene von politik und recht
spielen diese dinge eine rolle
aber wenn wir politik und recht nach
maßstäben der gerechtigkeit ausrichten
wollen müssen wir auch hier diese diese
moralische form des respekts mit
beachten dass spielt in vielen fragen
demokratie aber auch migration wo
insbesondere schüler zu gearbeitet hat
eine wichtige rolle
sie hatten ursprünglich nach dem
realitätssinn dieser theorie gefragt und
hier wird man vielleicht zwei drei sagen
müssen erstens ein moralisch ein prinzip
wie der kategorische imperativ oder
jedes prinzip einer moral auch der
utilitarismus muss natürlich unser
reales handeln orientieren und auch
korrigieren können
das heißt wir können die moral nicht
ablesen an dem wir uns tagtäglich
verhalten
sie muss aber etwas sein was wir in
unserem täglichen verhalten beherzigen
können an dem wir uns orientieren und
mit mitteln der vernunft uns korrigieren
können deshalb ist sein ein stück
realität transzendenz also jetzt
einfacher ausgedrückt die wirklichkeit
korrigieren können an prinzipien gehört
zu jeder viel es ist nicht nur so habe
man generell wissen wo man hin will wo
man noch nicht ist was müsste sich dann
konkret jetzt ändern also weicht die
realität eklatant von diesem ideal ab
also was würden sie sagen sind konkrete
politische forderungen die man direkt
aus diesem prinzip ableiten kann
also ist zunächst mal und war einige
albert aber ist dass die einbeziehung
der anderen in einer demokratischen
gesellschaft leben ja nicht nur die von
stimmungs berechtigt sind leben auch
viele andere menschen die irgendwann ja
natürlich einige bilder sind zum
natürlichen natürlich und die unter
diesen gesetzen unterwerfen werden aber
die keine der schwach oder
beteiligungsrecht haben also wie kann
dann das geschehen und natürlich hier
bewegen wir uns weg von der moral
theorie ein bisschen zu der ethischen
fragen wie wollen wir miteinander leben
vernünftig leben und zu der politischen
theorie was müssen wir in der
gesellschaft ändern also wie können wir
die leute die nicht die formelle sprach
rechte stimmung sagte wald rechte erben
also mit ein bisschen ja also das ein
sehr schönes metapher die einbeziehung
der anteil gilt als geschehen kann
im konkreten jetzt ein wahl und
stimmrecht für ausländer in sande zum
beispiel herr forst für sie ja aber
die politischen entscheidungen die in
einem land getroffen werden haben wir
auswirkungen die nicht nur in diesem
land stattfinden das heißt also abermals
ist jemand der nicht nur forderungen
normativer forderungen stellt sondern
über die politik nachdenkt die
transnational operiert aber eben nicht
nur transnational operiert sondern auch
transnationale legitimiert werden muss
da kommt sein interesse an einem
demokratischen europa eigentlich ja das
ist nicht so dass er jetzt ein europäer
wäre der sagt ah wir sind der tollste
kontinent der welt wir müssen irgendwas
zusammen machen sondern das ist eine
erste substanzielle form transnationale
politik zu institutionalisieren
aber wer seine theorie ernst nimmt wie
er selbst natürlich tut auch in seinen
politischen stellungnahmen die ja zu den
philosophischen passen aber jetzt nicht
identisch immer direkt aus den
philosophischen weichenstellungen folgen
ist klar dass europa europäische politik
auch eine rechtfertigung pflicht hat
gegenüber nicht europäern in der
migrationsfrage ist das evident aber in
vielen anderen ökonomischen ökologischen
fragen ist dass er weder das heißt also
die forderung nach universalistischen
transnationalen form der politik ist
nicht einfach nur moralische forderung
sondern sie ist eine die angesichts der
globalen probleme mit denen wir heute in
welchem staat auch immer zu tun haben
das ist eine frage die wir auf den tisch
legen müssen weil die probleme anders
nicht zu bewältigen sind wer heute tag
bei control ruft und meint im
nationalstaat alles wieder herstellen zu
können ist unrealistisch insofern ist
die harbor master theorie auch mit einem
guten stück realismus ausgestattet
also das sehr interessant bei der ganzen
immigrations diskussion ja also man
diskutiert dass sie in europa so also
plötzlich diese afrikanische menschen
vor lampedusa stehen man fragt sich
nicht war und man verbinden dass auch
mit der europäischen wirtschaft politik
überhaupt nicht aber wir wissen dass zum
beispiel das agrarpolitik von der
europäischen union sehr schädliche
wirkungen auf den afrikanischen bauern
gehabt haben
das globale zusammenhänge internationale
macht beziehungen letztlich globale
probleme die wir lösen müssen und die
können wir nicht jeder für sich
nationalstaatlich lösen sondern es ist
braucht irgendwie eben ein so etwas wie
eine eu und das aber eine demokratisch
legitimierte verein politisch
vereinigtes europa wofür sich habermann
sehr stark einsetzt jetzt ist es so mit
dem konsens ist es ja nicht so leicht
dass er sagte eigentlich müssten alle
dem zustimmen können aber die tendenz
geht derzeit in eine ganz andere
richtung nämlich in nationalistische
stimmen werden werden laut was macht man
jetzt das abermals jahren abermals ihr
also die sache mit dem konsens gut dass
sie es ansprechen ansprechen das wird
das wird oft missverstanden es ist nicht
so dass habermas sagt wir können erst in
bezug auf politische oder moralische
fragen sicherheit haben wenn ein
eindeutiger konsens hergestellt ist dann
hätte man ja nie sicher
die idee des konsenses ist eine
kontrolle faktisch eine notwendige
annahme die annahme ist eigentlich ganz
einfach wenn wir uns hier über etwas
unterhalten dann gehen wir davon aus
dass dieses etwas von uns erkannt werden
kann und zwar nicht nur von mir ganz
anders als von ihnen sondern wir setzen
voraus dass wir uns verständigen können
über etwas das heißt wir setzen voraus
dass wir im grunde einen konsens
erzielen können müssten sonst würden
unsere gespräche ganz anders ablaufen
wir können uns nicht alles ernst nehmen
als gesprächspartner wenn wir nicht
davon überzeugt sind dass sie mich
überzeugen können und ich sie und
schiller
insofern ist der konsens eine notwendige
annahme eines vernünftigen gespräch ist
mir gleich nach hause gehen aber das ist
das gleich ist nicht erst vernünftig
wenn wir einen konsens erzielt haben
interessant ich habe mich als schweizer
natürlich noch überlegt wie das mit der
direkten demokratie ist mit
mitbestimmung und dem der zustimmung
aller oder der meisten dies da
eigentlich habermas haltungen also wir
haben in der schweiz sehr viele
abstimmungen die zum teil auch sehr
kompliziert sind diese vorlagen über
über steuerreformen und ahv aus der
altersvorsorge und viele verstehen da
die details überhaupt nicht und müssen
trotzdem irgendwie ihre stimme abgeben
ist das eine gute idee wie wir steht
habermas zu dieser idee von direkter
demokratie also ich glaube im grunde
genommen natürlich direkte demokratie
ist da auch also eine kernidee von
demokratie also ich würde überhaupt ich
meine es gibt die iss der gegensatz
zwischen direkter demokratie und
repräsentative demokratie wo die
parteien oder andere strukturen also und
sobald das volk repräsentieren und in
meisten fällen sind demokratische
staaten also repräsentative demokratie
an
ob das nur eine frage der größe ist oder
auch eine frage der geschichte und der
kultur ja also in komplexe
gesellschaften direkte demokratie end
finden auf andere ebenen statt zum
beispiel auf einem stadtregierung gern
wahlkreis im usability was wir im juni
city und der city gehen
also insofern ist die fundamentale und
wie man das institutionalisiert in der
schweiz
ihr habt eine andere eine andere
tradition an natürlich nun
noch etwas auf die idee
demokratietheorie also abermals hat
immer verfassung und demokratie in seine
idee vom gleich ursprünglichkeit von
menschenrechten und volkssouveränität
verbunden
und heute ist also gefahr dass
volkssouveränität gegen über die
menschenrechte gestellt wird und als
eine art von ampass mystische
nationalistische verkörperung von herrn
oder salvini und so weiter verstanden
dass ihre daumen dass folgt dass gegen
minderheiten oder gegen grundrechte
jänner kollidieren das ist jetzt im
moment die gefahr die wir laufend als
eine idee fand volkssouveränität
rechtspopulistisch interpretiert wird
und da scheidet das natürlich die rechte
der minderheiten seit es die migranten
sei dass die sexuelle minderheiten sei
dass die ethnische minderheit also dass
das ist auch die gefahr die gefahr im
moment nur bestätigen habermas
demokratietheorie ist schon immer eine
kritische theorie gewesen das heißt also
seit dem buch das ich eingangs erwähnt
habe über den strukturwandel der
öffentlichkeit ist er sich sehr klar
darüber wie viele formen der verzerrung
von informationen meinungs- flüssen
abstimmungen es in demokratischen
gesellschaften westlichen gesellschaften
gibt das ist also teil der analyse die
die analyse ist immer doppelt es ist ein
soziologischer realismus in bezug auf
sozusagen die verzerrungen einer
öffentlichkeit oder demokratischer oder
populistischer diskussionen aber
gleichzeitig zeit die kälte am standards
fest die wir brauchen um eine verzerrung
überhaupt eine verzerrung zu nennen
verstehen sie da wenn man also deshalb
sagt aber dass die theorie kann ja nicht
aufgehen denn die die leute sind ja
nicht informiert und die gehen nach
bestimmten vorurteilen und so weiter
wenn man sowas kritisiert
dann muss man einen standard
voraussetzen wie den den er aus arbeitet
man muss also weit es tun
sowohl die kritik vollziehen wie auch
die prinzipien ausweisen und wenn sie
mir um auf den auf die die frage von
volkssouveränität und menschenrechten
noch einmal kurz zurück zu kommen die
die schweizer zuschauer mögen es mir
verzeihen aber die frage von
minderheitenrechten wird eben auch dort
virulent wo es um religiöse minderheiten
geht und wenn man also eine
volksabstimmung hätte angenommen so was
gelber ist mit einer großen mehrheit
dass moscheen aber keine minarette geben
soll dann ist das dann ist die frage ist
das eine demokratisch legitim abstimmung
wenn minderheitenrechte in dieser weise
eingeschränkt werden dann sehen sie wie
das prinzip der menschenrechte hier
bestimmte schranken errichtet gegenüber
das gegenüber dem was mehrheiten wohl
schließen können das ist bestimmte dinge
können mehrheit nicht beschließen weil
sie grundregeln des respekts verletzten
jetzt wollen wir mal dieses ideal noch
ein bisschen unter die lupe nehmen und
vielleicht auch kritisch also wenn man
alle betroffenen mitbestimmen lassen
soll und die stimme anhören soll dann
geht es in bestimmten fällen gar nicht
denken wir anwesen die keine sprache
haben tiere zum beispiel oder menschen
die noch nicht geboren sind zukünftige
generationen
die können noch nicht reden und ihre
stimme erheben wie geht man mit diesen
beiden problemen aus einer habermas in
sicht
also im der maßstab sich allen gegenüber
nicht nur der idee nach sondern
tatsächlich rechtfertigen zu müssen ist
auch dann ein hilfreicher maßstab wenn
genau in den beispielen die sie erwähnen
es gar nicht praktizierbar ist mit
personen die vielleicht ihre sprache
verloren haben noch nicht geboren sind
in einen kommunikativen zusammenhang zu
treten wie so weil wir ganz oft nicht
nur in solchen beispielen entscheidungen
fällen müssen die andere betreffen mit
denen wir jetzt momentan keine
kommunikation herstellen können
wir müssen uns also immer fragen ist das
was ich tue rechtfertigbar auch dann
wenn es keine institution oder form der
konkreten rechtfertigung gibt wir müssen
also beides tun wir müssen nach
institutionen und nach formen suchen wo
rechtfertigung aus den konventionellen
bahnen heraus erweitert wird
aber die frage für uns ob moralisch
rechtfertigbar ist gegenüber zb
künftigen generationen was wir hier tun
die nimmt uns keiner ab die können wir
nicht vertragen und sagen keine angst so
aber es die für interessen haben das ist
einfach die frage unserer moralischen
vorstellungskraft
ob wir in der lage sind unsere eigenen
interessen zu trans sind hier
transzendieren und andere zur sprache zu
bringen die aber im moment keine sprache
haben genau aber das kann ja eigentlich
das bleibt ja ein stück weit spekulation
also wenn ich jetzt denke die werden dem
auch zustimmen
ein chinese zum beispiel eine inderin
oder meine urenkel
ich muss doch eigentlich mit denen reden
oder dann sonst setzt sich so etwas wie
eine universelle vernunft voraus also
das sind natürlich in der theorie auch
unterschiedliche antworten möglich also
ich habe einen anderen weg gewählt
diesem problem umzugehen und das ein
bisschen die unterscheidung zwischen
unsere moral in theorie an hier also
formell kann man sagen dann muss man
ganz einfach stellvertreter diskurs zu
führen
eine andere idee ist auf das einzugehen
das in der moral ist nicht nur um wissen
geht aber um körperliche menschen
verkörperte menschen die auch wenn oft
ausüben
das ist auch eine idee die man in der
späten arbeiten von haben als findet
dass wir verletzliche menschen sind und
dass auch diese unsere verletzlichkeit
beruht auch die letzten endes auf die
tatsache dass wir verkörperte
unsterbliche wesen sind für mich war
dieser gedanke also dass das verläuft
wesen auch 1 in borden clijsters
verkörperte ist sehr hilfreich um diese
perspektive von der verallgemeinerten
und an konkreten andern einzubeziehen
also werden wir mit kant werden in der
vernunft moral der andere ist jemandem
er in allen hinsichten gleich ist unsere
differenzen sind irrelevant
wir sind für eine oft lesen aber im
alltagsleben in dem moralischen
auseinandersetzungen natürlich wir sind
konkret verkörperte menschen und unser
verständigung und also die möglichkeit
einer verständigung zu kommen kann von
diesen differenzen nicht sehen sondern
muss sozusagen immanent mit den mit den
arbeiten also und diese diese zog diese
interpretativen zug ermöglicht einem der
gedanke von unserer beziehung zu der
natur
wir sind ja ein teil der natur was was
soll es also und aber auch zu der
zukünftigen generation und zwar konkret
sollen also das ist das eine
mögliche erweiterung und anwendung der
disco stick der ein bisschen auch mit
feministischer theorie zusammengebracht
werden kann soll man dann vielleicht
auch die tiere die zwar nicht sprechen
können aber die verletzliche wesen sind
irgendwie mit ins boot und diese
ausdrucks wenig sind ja sehr expressiv
durch das verhalten ja jetzt haben wir
so einen der vielleicht den
grundgedanken von von jürgen habermas
ein bisschen kennen gelernt habe was ist
aber nicht nur ein theoretiker sondern
auch ein praktiker der öffentlichkeit
denn er mischt sich immer wieder ein hat
das dein leben lang gemacht opposition
europa geht die letzten jahre ob es um
kriegseinsätze gegangen ist im kosovo
zum beispiel um bioethik und klonen und
so weiter und in diesem öffentlichen
engagement hat er schon sehr früh
angefangen als junger journalist greift
habermas 1953 den philosophen martin
heidegger an heidecker hatte in den 30er
jahren in einer vorlesung über die
innere größe und wahrheit des
nationalsozialismus gesprochen später
veröffentlichte heidecker die vorlesung
unkommentiert im muff der 50er jahre
fürchtet habermas einen rückfall in alte
mentalitäten diese angst verbindet ihn
mit theodor w adorno der habermas 1956
als assistent ans frankfurter institut
für sozialforschung holt in den 60er
jahren wird habermas professor für
philosophie in frankfurt und unterstützt
den kampf der 68er für mehr
liberalisierung
doch der linksliberale macht mit seiner
kritik vor dem eigenen milieu nicht halt
er wirft dutschke links faschismus vor
bezeichnet die proteste als schein
revolution warnt vor aktionismus
sorgt sich um die traditionen des
rechtsstaates
habermas als verfassungs loyaler linke
aber auch als dezidierte kapitalismus
kritiker damals zumindest wie ist das
heute eigentlich
naja das ist heute die
kapitalismuskritik ist natürlich immer
noch da aber man muss schon sehen wie
sich der kapitalismus gewandelt hat und
ich denke dass die weichenstellung die
er in der theorie des kommunikativen
handelns vorgenommen hat immer noch
gelten das heißt er analysiert die art
wie das kapitalistische
wirtschaftssystem nicht nur ressourcen
der natur nutzt vernichtet sondern auch
wie es ausbeuterische gerade auch
transnational ausbeuterische
ökonomischer verhältnisse produziert und
unterstützt aber eben auch die art wie
das was er system oder wirtschaftssystem
nennt lebenswelten kolonisiert das heißt
also bestimmte lebensbereiche auf
ökonomisches denken umstellt also das
heißt kapitalismus kritik hat ganz viele
ganz viele facetten bei ihm also
kolonisierung der lebenswelt heißt dass
bestimmte lebens lebensbereiche sein
rationalisiert werden
sagen wir mal eben das bildungssystem
wird umgestellt auf bestimmte output
orientierungen und ergebnisorientierung
wo ökonomische effizienz eine größere
rolle spielt nicht dass das völlig
sinnlos wäre
aber man muss natürlich schauen wie
bestimmte ökonomische rationalität in
lebensbereiche eindringen die vielleicht
nach anderen gesetzen organisiert sein
sollten
da würde sagen weniger privatisierung
mehr staat indiana privatisierung heißt
ja dann auch dass eine bestimmte art zu
denken und zu handeln einzug hält in
bestimmte lebens und arbeitsbereiche sie
haben jetzt das buch schon mal erwähnt
dass er 1961 geschrieben hat den
strukturwandel der öffentlichkeit das
war seine habilitationsschrift darin
erzählt er wie öffentlichkeit
bürgerliche öffentlichkeit entsteht
ausgehend von literarischen salons
tischgesellschaften bis hin zur zu den
medien zu den klassischen medien wie
zeitungen und so weiter und wie auch
wieder so ein verfahren stattfindet
durch diese kommerzialisierung damals
jetzt erleben wir seit einigen jahren
einen neuen strukturwandel der
öffentlichkeit nämlich durch das
internet durch die digitalisierung durch
soziale medien wie facebook twitter
youtube usw
wie beurteilen sie denn diesen wandel
dieser revolution als perspektive also
ich glaube es zunächst mal vielleicht
vor 20 jahren oder so ich hatte
persönlich auch mehr freiheiten mit
diesen entwicklung verbunden und ich
will erklären was ich damit meine zum
beispiel ist so etwas entstanden wie ist
es als journalist dass plötzlich jeder
schon eine journalismus ja dass leute
angefangen haben über geschichten und
soll zählen oder zum beispiel in den usa
gewalt gegenüber schwarze jugendliche
sind sehr viele aufnahmen dann filme und
so weiter video aufnahmen entstanden die
von den beteiligten selbst also von m
also das war eine große leistung und wir
dachten okay jetzt eröffnet sich die
öffentlichkeit diese in europa monopole
von der großen sendungen wird gebrochen
da kommt dann wissen also mehr freiheit
und luft uns aber was wir auch jetzt
sehr gefährliche fragmentierung und
fragmentierung in dem sinne dass werden
unsere studenten zum beispiel morgens
also ihre computer an machen sie gehen
nur an diese seiten wo sie hingehen
öffnen für nachrichten ja also es gibt
keinen zwang jetzt also die einigermaßen
gesamte öffentlichkeit wahrzunehmen also
der einwand wäre wieso ist eine zeitung
eine gesamte öffentlichkeit jede zeitung
hat also politik und so weiter also wie
soll es aber da ist was anderes also
wenn ich eine zeitung lese muss ich auch
also andere nachrichten wahrnehmen und
als was mir gefällt oder was mir nicht
gefällt und ich glaube die politische
polarisierung hat auch einige massen mit
dieser was auch manchmal infoteam und
information und entertainment wird also
in dem sinne ist die dieses versprechen
von der neuen öffentlichkeit glaube ich
komplexe will es nicht ganz einfach
abweisen
aber es hat wirklich sehr schattenseiten
aber sie zersplittert in so einer wie
man das immer wieder hört und dadurch
stärkt sich die polarisierung was macht
man dagegen das lehrt uns die
entwicklung der moderne dialektisch zu
betrachten was heißt also es gibt
rationalität gewinne und rationalität
verluste
und das ist mit den neuen medien genauso
es gibt all die phänomenologie scheler
erwähnt aber es gibt genauso aufstände
billionen wie sie von einigen jahren
genannt wurden oder heute das was in
hongkong geschehen erst das wäre ohne
soziale medien so nicht möglich
die ausweitung die diese medien
ermöglichen auf bevölkerungsteile die
vorher an medialen diskussionen wenig
partizipierten das muss man alles auch
bedenken wenn man wenn man über diese
neuen medien spricht die art wie meine
kinder sich heute innerhalb von sekunden
informieren können was für politische
vorgänge in china ablaufen und ja da
gibt es auch viele falsche seite
aber wenn ich denke wie ich noch in
meiner schulzeit an lexika kommen musste
die dann in der regel veraltet waren
bitte ja in den bibliotheken
dann können wir jetzt nicht einfach
sagen wir leben in einem gigantischen
des informationszeitalters ist einfach
sagst du auch nicht gesagt aber das ist
einfach nicht richtig
die sache mit den mit den segmentierten
kammern mit den segmentierten parallel
diskursen ist sehr ernst zu nehmen weil
wir auch radikalisierungen innerhalb
dieser medialen diskurse sehen die wie
jetzt in hessen in nordhessen wieder
geschehen
auch aus zu eklatant mörderischer gewalt
führen also wir müssen da sehr
vorsichtig sein in bezug auf
radikalisierungstendenzen die mit diesen
medialen diskurs in diesen sechs
segmentes kursen einher gehen wir müssen
aber auch die vergangenheit nicht
nostalgisch verklären
also parallel diskurs universen gab es
auch schon zur guten alten zeit der
zeitung und des radios also das ist in
einer form ist das jetzt neu aber als
phänomen jetzt nicht etwas was in den
letzten zehn jahren entstanden das heißt
man kann man diesen strukturwandel durch
die digitalisierung mit dem werk von
habermas gut erklären und irgendwie auch
lösungsansätze anbieten das würde mich
interessieren sind sie sind ja beide
denken und denke die in der tradition
von hamas stehen asyl rinnen schüler und
sein erbe ein bisschen weiter tragen in
neue gebiete hinein sie erforscht haben
bei jugend haben
aber was promoviert zur gerechtigkeit
dann bei seinem schüler ab so hornek
sich habilitiert zu toleranz gelten als
wichtigster deutscher philosoph seiner
generation haben den leibniz preis
gekriegt für wen
nein das muss man außerdem lassen sie
sich nicht unterbrechen man könnte mit
ihnen beiden jeweils eine stimme die
anderen machen
bei ihnen ist es so sie haben
biografisch finde ich ganz spannend sie
sind in der türkei aufgewachsen in einer
familie sephardischer juden haben so
multikulturell und internationalen
familien hängt der grund und das
spiegelt sich auch in der theorie wir
haben schon gespürt dieser dieses
kosmopolitische denken migration ist ein
großes thema für sie aber auch
feminismus
was ist denn jetzt das potenzial das man
heute von habermas sozusagen
herausnehmen musste wo muss man ihnen
weiter denken heute egal wie
soziologisch die öffentlichkeit sich
ändert ohne die gedanken der
öffentlichkeit gibt es keine demokratie
dass das ist das ist fundamental
weil also die öffentlichkeit kann eine
kommune sein als eine region sein
und heute muss das transnationale seien
aber die öffentlichkeit heißt auch also
dieses 2 wo die kommunikation die
miteinander kommunizieren stattfinden
und vor gründe genannt werden und
gründen ausgedruckt werden die haben
auch ein bestehen also das ist toll aber
das ist doch heute gerade auf globaler
ebene der digitalen raum also wo wird wo
tauscht man sich aus über die sozialen
medien über whatsapp über facebook über
twitter über das internet foren usw also
dass sie nicht den libera tief okay
eigentlich ein talent das sind kleine
der liebe relative medien was heißt der
liberati in dem sinne dass es nicht also
über eine zukünftige entscheidung über
einen sachverhalt
umstritten wird gründe genannt werden
what's up at work lockt nicht da also
was soll da ich meine das ist nicht eine
auseinandersetzung der nähe also die
medien viele können das ermöglichen aber
im grunde genommen glaube ich irgendwo
müssen die menschen doch zusammen sitzen
und miteinander reden und miteinander
diskutieren und eine andere als
miteinander kommunizieren die medien
können da helfen ich glaube nicht aber
im grunde genommen dass demokratie das
ist ein tag über medien geführt dass das
geht ja sondern es braucht räume positiv
zivilgesellschaft irgendwie treffen kann
formieren kann ja wir brauchen foren und
formen real stattfinden da das große und
die politik kann nicht entlastet werden
davon solche diskurse selbst zu führen
dort wo es in parlamenten geschieht aber
es auch eben gesellschaftlich zu führen
und dort wo sie nur nach
umfrageergebnissen agiert haben wir
schon ein problem weil natürlich politik
auch überzeugen muss und in die
öffentlichkeit hinein wirken muss sie
kann er nicht nur sie kann ja nicht nur
reagieren was die globale natur der
politik angeht ist das wieder so dass
wir das in seiner ganzen ambivalenz
betrachten müssen wir leben in einer
zeit in der die insbesondere westliche
wirtschaftsweise aber auch die aufholen
industrielle sektoren etwa in china oder
in indien extern ali täten produziert
also auswirkungen hat globaler natur
etwa ökologischer art aber eben auch
sagen
einzelne regionen in der welt werden zu
ressourcen lieferanten
und andere stellen die produkte her die
dann für teures geld wieder in die
länder der ressourcen lieferanten
geliefert werden das heißt also
transnational haben wir es mit einem
großen system von abhängigkeiten
asymmetrien und ungerechtigkeiten zu tun
aber zugleich leben wir in einer zeit in
der wir so viel mehr wissen können über
diese probleme über die zusammenhänge
aber eben auch wie und das rührt an die
frage die schüler im vorhin vor der
pause auf geworfen hat wir wissen auch
mehr über kulturelle besonderheiten
kulturelle traditionen anderer
nichtwestlicher gesellschaften so dass
also wir hier in einem lernprozess sind
und das ist für haben wir mal sehr
wichtig einerseits sein leben wir noch
in einer wirtschaftsweise die uns
bevorteilt und andere andere
asymmetrisch benutzt aber wir können
heute mehr wissen wir können uns nicht
nur indem wir reisen obwohl das mit den
reisen wird ja im ökologischen zeitalter
jetzt wieder etwas schwieriger aber habe
begegnungen mit menschen aus anderen
kulturen anderen gesellschaften sind
heute so viel häufiger als wenn sie sich
überlegen wie das vor 50 oder vor 80
jahren war
und da findet natürlich etwas stadt das
ist ja nicht so dass man dass man da
hingeht und die die leute wie die dort
leben als aliens betrachter manchmal
schon aber aber es findet heute ein
kommunikativer austausch statt der
glaube ich etwas bewirken kann wenn man
die probleme richtig benennen
also dieser ungeheure prozess der
globalisierung der vielen auch angst
macht ist für habermas habe ich sie
richtig verstehe eine chance also sein
fernziel ist also etwas wie eine welt
bürgergemeinschaft habe ich gelesen wie
stellt er sich das vor als eine föderale
welt republik oder so was die
demokratisch strukturiert ist ist das
das fenster
na ja also das muss das beantworte nicht
machst dann ganz kurz die vereinten
nationen muss man als institution
natürlich interpretieren man kann sagen
oh das ist nur ein klub einiger
mächtiger staaten und die anderen haben
da nichts mitzureden
das ist die eine sichtweise die andere
sichtweise ist die potenziale zu sehen
die überhaupt dort existieren wo es
transnationale internationale
institutionen gibt und dass wir bei
bestimmten fragen nicht nur krieg und
frieden sondern auch der ökologischen
frage aber auch ökonomische denken sie
nur an die finanzkrise und wie viel an
regulation nötig wäre und vielleicht
nicht geschehen ist um solche krisen die
ja überall auf der welt ihre
auswirkungen haben
irgendwie zu bewältigen vielleicht sogar
eines tages zu verhindern es wird doch
gar kein weg daran vorbei die fragen zu
stellen wie die politischen
institutionen legitimerweise aussehen
müssten die solche probleme angehen was
heißt jetzt das ganz konkret also ich
habe den gedanken verstanden die großen
probleme die wir heute haben sind
globaler natur von migration
digitalisierung wirtschaftskrise und so
weiter ökologie und jetzt das müssen die
lösungen auch global sein aber was heißt
das
was sind die nächsten schritte ganz
gedreht was braucht es ja ich meine die
philosophen sind nicht dafür da für
zustände zu sagen
what is to be done die frage fahren
lernen etwa aber ich meine wir müssen
versuchen in der diskurs natürlich auch
mit ideen zu beteiligen und ich will
jetzt auf etwas sagen was rainer gesagt
hat es ist glaube ich sehr schwer ich in
der globalen
sie will gesellschaft auch heute mit
dieser aufeinanderprallen der religionen
kulturen und so weiter leben zu lernen
ja und ich will jetzt ein bisschen aus
der eine aus europäischer perspektive
was was sagen sogar in der europäischen
union sind immer noch zwei sich
widersprechende ideen auf einer seite
von eine kosmopolitismus dino auf der
kita basiert ist und auf der anderen
seite die idee dass kerneuropa
christlich bleibt also ich konnte hier
stundenlang über die tragik und die
probleme von der türkei auf noch mehr
und so weiter werden das will ich
natürlich nicht machen aber ich glaube
diese diese ideen von einer
föderalistischer kosmopolitismus auf der
einen seite und kulturelle und religiöse
unterschiede auf der anti ferenc sind
auf der einen seite und wie wir damit
der mit umgehen ist eine der größten
fragen
und jetzt da gibt's keine einfache
antworten aber man muss regulative ideen
haben wie wir weiter weiterkommen und
eine grundfrage scheint mir zu sagen wie
so etwas wie globale solidarität in
entstehen kann schon im europäischen rat
eines der großen themen hamas
solidarität neben der sprache er selbst
der aus biografischen notiz interessant
mit einer gaumenspalte zur welt gekommen
ist diese tatsache hat ihn sagt er
selbst und auch sein sein biograf stefan
mit alu nicht unwesentlich geprägt jetzt
sie haben schon angesprochen dieser
kultur klar steffi lais stattfinden kann
wenn es um globale zivilgesellschaft
geht um religion die wichtiger werden
auch für habermas in den letzten jahren
jahrzehnten aus
immer wieder wichtiger geworden ich
würde mit ihnen gerne jetzt gegen
schluss der sendung noch ein bisschen
über die religion sprechen welche rolle
sollten die haben in der öffentlichkeit
also das ist ein großes thema und sie
haben völlig recht dass er in seinen in
den letzten jahren vielleicht schon 15
jahren aber das kulminiert jetzt in dem
großen buch das im herbst erscheint sich
nicht nur die frage gestellt hat welche
rolle religion religion im öffentlichen
diskurs im politischen diskurs spielen
kann ob also religiöse gründe ganz außen
vor bleiben müssen oder wie etwa rolls
meinte wenn eine übersetzbar kein
religiöser gründe in eine säkulare
sprache möglich ist wieso man dann
religiöse gründe ausschließen sollte
aber was übersetzt heißt das hat
habermas eine weile beschäftigt bis
heute heißt übersetzt barkeit dass wir
etwa religiöse vorstellungen von
solidarität auch mit früheren
generationen etwa wie wir sie war walter
benjamin oder anderen finden dass das
wir dafür noch eine sprache haben das
heißt also der säkulare post
metaphysische denker habermas ist auf
fragen gestoßen und ein anlass war also
die bioethische debatte als gesagt wurde
warum sollten wir eigentlich wenn wir es
könnten nicht genetisch optimierte
menschen herstellen
dann ist so wenn man jemand der religiös
etwa aus dem christlichen aber nicht nur
unseren christlichen kontext denkt er
sagt ja weil man nicht gott spielen darf
das kann ein säkularer denke ja nicht
sagen ja und dann dann ist zeichnet dass
habermas aus dass es sich fragt ja was
sagt man dazu
wie kann man die haie intuition ja die
vielleicht aus der religion noch kommt
dass er sich dieser traktion versprach
ich nicht hier eingeladen und so sehen
sie deshalb darf man dieses neue projekt
nicht missverstehen der hamas ist nicht
in einem gewissen alter jetzt plötzlich
religiös geworden aber eher ein 1 6 1
durch und durch säkularer denker
den zeichnet es eben aus dass er sich
irritieren lässt von bestimmten fragen
die ethisch aufgeworfen werden und dann
und dann fragst du dich ja ab was habe
ich denn eigentlich für antworten darauf
und manchmal wird daraus eine so große
frage dass ein wieder sehr dickes buch
daraus resultiert dass ich alle freunde
von 1.700 erscheint im herbst sein muss
muss sein
der titel leitet eine andere geschichte
der philosophie es soll auch um dieses
verhältnis von philosophie und religion
gehen dass mit dieser übersetzung des
religiösen in etwas nicht religiöses sie
haben ein beispiel genannt wäre ein
anderes die menschenwürde wo man
sozusagen das budget der
gottesebenbildlichkeit des menschen hat
und jetzt sucht man irgendwie einen
säkularen nichtreligiösen begriff dafür
und nennt das würde also beide
verfassung von der
menschenrechtserklärung nehmen also
heißt das als die philosophen und andere
die sich daran beteiligt haben das
berühmte satz von kassel also was habt
ihr dort verabschiedet
die würde des menschen ist unantastbar
und alle mitglieder der menschenfamilie
sind gleich auf freiheit und würde uns
erweitern und also der spruch war
wir haben uns verständigt aber bitte
fragt uns nicht wollen oder was die
gründe waren und das ist ein
entspannendes moment weil bei dieser
jungen reis declaration waren
katholische dank chinesischer danke also
danke die aus russland kam und also
islamische banker die tagelang darüber
diskutiert haben und sie haben sich über
diese begriffe und jungen dignity
menschenwürde
ja ich nicht also das glaube ich ist
eine sehr schönes beispiel für was immer
vorschwebt die möglichkeit dass so eine
verständigung
da ist die ganz grundlegenden werte des
zusammenlebens weil man auch sagen muss
das ja es gibt religiöse begriff der
menschenwürde und schiller hat zurecht
auf diese genealogie dieser
menschenrechtserklärung hingewiesen aber
es gibt natürlich auch einen eine nicht
religiöse tradition davon und wieder
sind wir bei kant bekannt liegt die
menschenwürde darin dass wir gesetzgeber
sind im reich der zwecke und dass jeder
den anderen als gleiche autorität
ansehen muss über moralische normen
befinden und mit entscheiden zu können
moralische normen die unser gemeinsames
zusammenleben regeln in diesem
verständnis von autorität und würde
nämlich gesetzes unterworfener und
gesetzgeber zugleich zu sein kann man
jetzt auch wieder natürlich eine
christliche genealogie rekonstruieren
aber der gedanke ist nicht ein
religiöser sondern die autonomie die
selbst gesetzgebung steht im zentrum
zum schluss der sendung würde ich gerne
ganz konkret nochmal werden
und sie fragen wie ich denn jetzt
abermals in meinen alltag mitnehmen kann
cabanas toko wie kann ich morgen
aufstehen und etwas von dem umsetzen was
er uns hinterlassen hat was er
geschrieben hat
die demokratie einzunehmen und nicht
denken dass es immer bestehen wird und
heute sind sehr gefährliche strömungen
die auch von mir zu hause aus konnten in
den usa
also ich stehe viele morgen auf und ich
sage wir die republik bestehen diese
gedanke kann man nicht so leicht runter
also dass eine weltweite gefahr es
entsteht eine neue motor technokratisch
muss also die ist eine versuchung die
wir heute eine versuchung sein für die
demokratie ein technokratie man ja eine
erfolgreiche technokratie bei vielen
jungen menschen wird auch jetzt gesagt
also eine vielleicht eine technokratie
eine experte kratie kann das
umweltproblem besser lösen als die
demokratien die wirklich jetzt also
unfähig geworden sind zu handeln und das
ist glaube ich auch
also ein moment wo wirklich es lohnt
sich mit habermas zu denken und zu
verstehen was diese errungenschaft eine
liberale demokratie ist ich habe ja eine
republik verloren die türkei ist jetzt
im meines erachtens einer logik bento
keine republik mehr also aber diese
grundgedanken von dem von einem habe war
ist also wie eine republik weiter
besteht eine liberal demokratische
republik weiter besteht also ich glaube
immer muss dass ich jeden morgen
vielleicht überlegen dass demokratie
nicht selbstverständlich ist er ab jetzt
darf ich noch ganz kurz nachfragen bevor
ich zu ihm kommen sie haben die ökologie
erwähnt dass viele jungen das delegieren
möchte ich an experten das klimaproblem
lösen aber derzeit formiert sich
widerstand mit diesen freitag streiks
friday sicher future
das ist doch zivilgesellschaft wie sie
leben sollen nach habermas habe ich denn
den eindruck das ist fantastisch sind
diese jugendbewegung gern in der neusser
auch entstand nicht so weit gegangen
vielleicht da ist auch meine perspektive
ein bisschen pessimistischer als was
jetzt hier möglichst selten selbst
schauen dass die jungen generationen das
macht jede generation bringt ihre
protestbewegung hervor sie haben eben an
habermas 68 erinnert aber man kann das
also den 15-jährigen schleifen durch
denken dann gab es die die
ökologiebewegung die anti atom bewegung
und zweiter und überall hat habermas
hinter wenn wichtige intervention ob es
um zivilen ungehorsam ging und so weiter
aber wir sollten auch nicht debatten wie
die über den historikerstreit etwa
vergessen das heißt aber must go heißt
kritische arbeit leisten heißt wenn
jemand im namen der demokratie
menschenrechte einschränken will
so sagen dass es nicht demokratie nicht
nationalistischen definitionen des
volkes auf den leim gehen und nicht so
zu tun als würden europäische
demokratien untergehen wenn sie sich
nicht länger christlich verstehen
sie gehen unter wenn sie sich verhärten
und nicht sehen wie man liberale und
demokratische und eben auch soziale
politik in der praxis umsetzen muss wenn
gesellschaften sich verändern das heißt
also habermas to go heißt wachsam zu
sein
in bezug auf die auch die semantischen
verschiebung also die begriffe mit denen
wir operieren und wenn sowie fehler das
gesagt hat leute versuchen den begriff
der demo der demokratie populistisch
umzudeuten
man muss man irgendwann sagen das hat
mit demokratie nichts mehr zu tun aber
nicht zu sagen ach hier gibt es einen
widerspruch zwischen menschenrechten und
demokratie in dem moment ist man schon
denen ein stück weit auf den leim
gegangen weil man ihnen
begriff der demokratie überlassen
demokratie heißt immer auch
menschenrechte wenn ich sehe wenn ich
sie richtig verstehe sie haben diesen
historikerstreit kurz erwähnt das muss
man vielleicht erklären also hamas ist
ja 29 geboren hat den krieg noch noch
miterlebt als junger jugendlicher und es
gab dann die debatte darum ob diese show
einzigartiges euro belassen
das relativieren kann und so weiter da
hat dass ich immer dafür eingesetzt die
vergangenheit so zwar ein ganz wichtiger
punkt wir haben das auch eingangs
eingespielt ist das denken nach maß in
bezug auf nationalismus insbesondere zu
verstehen aus der prägung seiner jugend
und dann sehen sie die heidecker debatte
und so weiter zusehen wie in der
bundesrepublik sich bestimmte diskurse
erhalten haben die ja immer aufs korn
genommen hat und entsprechend dann auch
ja auch harte diskussionen in der
öffentlichkeit hatte heute werte er ja
zu recht und schön gefeiert als
philosoph der bundesrepublik aber wenn
man mal in den büchern zurück bleibt
hier etwa weil müller dom dann sieht man
wie hart diese diskussion teilweise
geführt wurden und hier ist kann man
also anhand dieses werk das kann man so
sagen bestimmte identitäts diskussionen
und politische haltungen der deutschen
republik die kann man sehr gut nach
nachverfolgen herford frau benhabib ist
leider schon am ende der zeit ich nehme
mit dass ich morgen aufstehe und mit
kritischen augen die demokratie
hochhalte für den herzlichen dank gegen
beiden für das gespräch
ja und auch in vielen dank fürs mit
denken nächste woche spricht meine
kollegin barbara bleisch mit dem
australischen philosophen david james
mit dem experten wenn es um unseren
geist und um unser bewusstsein geht und
jetzt gleich geht es um die macht der
musik der dokumentarfilm der sound der
freiheit zeigt wie musik die welt
verändern kann von der masse ist bis zur
biomasse bleiben sie also dran und einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]